willkommen zurück weil carey antwortet
frage 1 für heute kommt von seventure
madonna oder sinkt hallo karin ich
möchte wissen ziehen sie ihre schuhe aus
wenn sie zu hause sind ja sehr wünscht
als ich diese frage zum ersten mal
gelesen habe dachte ich ehrlich gesagt
das ist eine ziemlich langweilige frage
ist aber wann habe ich mich eben hier
mit meiner kollegin im büro unterhalten
und die hat mir was interessantes
erzählt nämlich es gibt das gerücht oder
vorurteil dass alle ostdeutschen das
machen also zu hause ihre schuhe
ausziehen und alle westdeutschen nicht
also die schuhe anbehalten
davon hatte ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie
gehört ich finde das super interessant
da habe ich mal nachgedacht bei uns zu
hause also ich bin in westdeutschland
aufgewachsen
ich glaube meine schuhe meine eltern
haben die schuhe an lassen oder haben
pantoffeln auch etwas sehr typisch
deutsches pantoffeln oder hausschuhe
vielleicht habt ihr ja schon davon schon
mal gehört dass es eine mischung aus dem
einer waschstraße anzieht und socken
also irgendwie was bequem ist zu hause
ja ich auf jedenfalls hier die schule zu
hause aus ich ja keine ahnung ob das
jetzt so interessant ist für alle aber
ich mich interessieren wie ihr das hause
macht bzw was ihr aus deutschland kennt
das ja auch immer so ein
interkulturelles missverständnis ich
komme wo rein schuhe an lassen oder
ausziehen
akron el mago unser alter freund
schreibt zu unserer episode mit simon in
der kneipe kentix trainiert kids trinkt
bier in germany the time is understood
that
nein das stimmt tatsächlich 16-jährige
können schon legal biertrinken
deutschland und was noch schlimmer ist
die meisten tun es schon mit 13 oder mit
14 punkte
was sind pilz das wort habe ich nie
gehört aber viele leute haben ist
getrunken in dieser folge sehr gute
frage und da will ich sagen haben wir
einen offenbar sehr schlechten job
gemacht denn wir haben nicht erklärt was
ein pilz ist eines der wichtigsten worte
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich das wort pilz
als ein pilz also so much rum s
ich bin aber pilz ist auch eine
biersorte wie zum beispiel weizen ein
bier ist so ist auch pilz ein bier und
das ist eines der gängigsten wäre wenn
man also in die kneipe kommt und man
möchte kein weizen haben weizen kennt
ihr vielleicht aus bayern das sind diese
wäre dieser so ein bisschen hoch gehen
und ihr wollt so ein normales bier außen
zu fahren
dann bestellte im pilz zwei pilzmittel
carolyn rang schreibt is true that you
have to work in germany and all that but
i'm wondering if it's not ja kennen das
habe ich persönlich noch nie gehört aber
jetzt kommt ich habe gerade gehört dass
man das in china und korea macht ich
gebe also mal das vorurteil direkt
weiter von deutschland nach china und
korea hat mir gerade eine amerikanerin
erzählt ja wenn ihr aus china oder korea
kommt vielleicht könnt ihr das ja mal
bestätigen oder nicht beständigen in
deutschland macht man das auf jeden fall
nicht rülpsen beim essen ist total
unhöflich also wenn ihr nach deutschland
kommt wird er macht das nicht
scott robinson stellt eine sehr wichtige
frage gute folge dankes gott sind
deutsche wäre besser schmeckend in
deutschland als sie es im ausland sind
ich höre immer dass irische besser
irische bier besser schmecken in irland
ist das auch der fall für deutsches bier
das kommt sehr interessante frage die
ich dir leider auch nicht
hundertprozentig beantworten kann
denn ich habe noch gar nicht so viel
deutsches bier im ausland getrunken aber
ich kann bestätigen ich habe mal becks
im ausland probiert und es schmeckte
tatsächlich anders ich weiß leider nicht
mehr wo es war generell ist es leider so
dass es nicht viele deutsche bier im
ausland gibt und die die es gibt sind
nicht unbedingt die besten also so oder
so kann ich empfehlen wenn ihr gutes
deutsches bier trinken wollt dann kommt
unbedingt mal rein nach deutschland die
wichtigste frage für heute kommt von
maxxim 50 78 maxime fragt wieviel pippi
nach dem trinken ein
peter beer ja das weiß natürlich auch
nicht vielleicht einen meter das war auf
jeden fall die beste frage für heute
danke maxime für diese aufmerksame frage
so jetzt auch mal wieder eine frage
dient sich nicht um bier dreht jack apa
fragt uns ich finde das wort schaffen
schwierig zu verstehen weil es so viele
bedeutung hat create komplett stuff dann
manage establish und so weiter ich höre
das wort sehr oft und weiß nicht ganz
genau was ist bedeutet kipping aus dem
jacob das ist eine interessante frage
und zwar muss man dazu wissen dass das
wort ein hormonen ist und das heißt es
gibt zwei mal das wort schaffen das eine
wort ist im sinne von kreieren
zum beispiel dieser komponist hat viele
bedeutende werke geschaffen und es ist
aber gar nicht so populär als wort zum
beispiel man sagt gott hat die erde
geschaffen
aber das war das viel häufiger ist ist
das zweite schaffen und das ist er im
sinne von to manage zum beispiel wir
müssen schnell zum zug
aber wir sind schon spät dran wir
schaffen das nicht mehr
also wie we want managed to get the
train
das wäre eine übersetzung davon also
diese beiden bedeutung gibt es die
zweite ist allerdings viel häufiger also
wenn du das hörst und es geht darum
etwas zu machen oder nicht mehr zu
machen
ich weiß es ist nicht so einfach weil es
sehr ähnlich ist aber ja ein tipp noch
von janosch dazu diese beiden werben
werden auch unterschiedlich konjugiert
das eine ist nämlich regelmäßig das
anderes unregelmäßig das schaffen im
sinne von to manage das dicke nimmt man
regelmäßig nämlich schaffen schaffen
schaffte geschaffen geschafft supergut
sich unterrichtet deutsch schaffen
schaffte geschafft
das zweite das schaffen im sinne von
kreieren ist schaffen schuf geschaffen
am siebten tag schuf gott die erde ja
wann kommen wir jetzt schon zu der
auflösung unseres weihnachtsgewinnspiels
ihr erinnert euch wir haben weihnachten
dieses wunderbare buch verlost was ich
ja selber auch zu weihnachten verschenkt
habe und hier sind eure antworten darauf
unser erstes video kommt von jona aus
england und sie hatte uns dieses video
geschickt wo sie erklärt warum sie
dieses buch haben möchte und zwar dieses
buch hatten wir verlost und ja du bist
unsere gewinnerin leona weil du hast uns
als erstes geantwortet du hast ein super
video gemacht und du bist erst 14 jahre
alt und sprichst mega mega gut deutsch
und das möchte natürlich unterstützen
deswegen bekommst du dieses buch von uns
zu weihnachten als verspätetes
weihnachtsgeschenk
aber es ist ja weihnachten gewesen und
an weihnachten möchte natürlich
möglichst viele leute glücklich machen
hiervon haben wir leider nur ein buch
aber wir haben noch drei sehr sehr coole
einsendungen erhalten und dafür haben
wir noch ein besonderes geschenk nämlich
diese beiden bücher deutsche grammatik
und die hat uns diesmal tobias schwartz
gesponsert ihr erinnert euch vielleicht
tobias kommentiert sehr häufig bei uns
und hilft euch als er beantwortet auch
sehr viele fragen einig hatte er quasi
seine eigene offline schau tobias
antwortet er hat eigentlich gesagt wir
sollen seinen namen nicht nennen aber
nicht nur das trotzdem
ich möchte mich bei ihm bedanken er hat
uns zwei bücher geschickt und diese
bücher werden auch an euch verlust ja
das nächste buch geht das erste buch von
diesen geht an laura ich bin mir gar
nicht sicher woher du kommst laura aber
du freust dich in deinem video so sehr
über ein buch aus deutschland deswegen
möchten wir unbedingt ein buch aus
deutscher schicken
hier ist ein buch deutsche grammatik
einfach kompakt und übersichtlich
das zweite
dieser wunderbare bücher geht an aim
wayne hat uns geschrieben
beziehungsweise ein video geschickt und
wayne hat ein video geschickt in dem er
sehr sehr gutes deutsch spricht hier
seht ihr das video und in dem er auch
erklärt hat warum er gerne dieses buch
haben möchte und weil das so gut gemacht
dass wayne kommst an ein buch von uns
bzw von tobias dieses buch geht an dich
und zu guter letzt gibt es noch einen
spezialpreis ein special preis nämlich
an unseren jüngsten zuschauer überhaupt
denn er ist noch gar nicht geboren
guckt euch mal dieses video hier an das
hat uns giancarlo geschickt und die
beiden lernen zusammen easy german und
sie möchten gerne das ist dieses buch
haben für ihr kind was bald auf die welt
kommt und das fanden wir so toll dass
ihr ein besonderes buch bekommt nämlich
fast 1000 german da drin sind allerdings
wollte nicht auf englisch keine sorge
sondern auf deutsch und das ganze ist
ein bilderbuch was noch passender ist
wie ein kind wahrscheinlich braucht euer
kind noch ein paar jahre bis es dieses
buch lesen kann
aber wir schicken euch das schon mal
jetzt vorab ihr seht ist es so eine art
ja ein ganzes bild was man mit kindern
wunderbar angucken kann und beschreiben
kann und dazu gibt es die vokabeln auf
deutsch also das geht an giancarlo und
deine wunderbare frau alles gute euch
und danke fürs zuschauen
ja das war es auch schon für diese woche
wieder tolle fragen dabei gewesen
wir haben noch mehr fragen die wir noch
gar nicht beantwortet haben die kommt
der nächste woche und in der
zwischenzeit schickt uns einfach noch
mehr fragen die witzigsten die besten
die interessantesten werden
hier immer vorgelesen am ende noch einen
dank an e-mails oder michael sich die
mich ganz sicher wie das ausgesprochen e
mail du bist einer unserer unterstützer
bei katrin und wir können das gar nicht
oft genug sagen danke euch dafür dass
ihr uns unterstützt e mail heute ganz
besonders einen ganz besonderen dank für
dich
zu ermöglichen arbeiten
ist nicht
eine französin
die programmpunkte zu schaffen